let's see who else we've got here what
about our caller from the five one three
area code who's there from five one
three today hey David it's Brandon from
Fort Lauderdale hey Brandon what's going
on hey David
so I was calling in I know you've dealt
with this sort of question a few times
and it's going to be off the topic of
politics and it's going to be more
towards the ethics of veganism so I just
wanted to challenge you a little bit
sure I don't know if you've heard of the
name the trait argument but the basic
premise is can you name a trait that is
present and humans that if it were in
animals that it would be morally
unacceptable to kill the animal in that
case I've never thought about that
and I can think about it and get back to
you and obviously it's a question that
has been predetermined to get a
particular response which allows you to
then make a particular claim but I mean
you know here's my thing in general I'm
I'm usually against any kind of
Universalist black/white drawings of
lines in the sand on almost every issue
so if the idea is to kind of foment a
discussion or create a discussion where
if such a trait cannot be named
therefore it is wrong to eat all animals
or something like that I mean I just I
just think that any kind any of those
sort of Universalist type arguments are
flawed systemically so I don't know that
whether I could or couldn't it wouldn't
really do much one way or the other for
my view okay that neck kind of makes
sense so thank you thank you for the
answer by the way I'm the the reason
that I asked is is it because I have yet
to found a find a trait that would make
it morally acceptable to kill an animal
whether it be intelligence their level
of sentience because if you say well the
chicken has the same amount of
intelligence as an animal would I kill a
human that has this
amount of intelligence as that chicken
oh no I obviously wouldn't do that yeah
so listen that's not an argument I would
even engage in so I don't know that it
makes sense to argue it with me but let
me ask you this why is that why is the
Nate this name a trait thing why do you
find it so important or why does it feel
like it's powerful to you because it's
based off of what I think is most
valuable in humans which obviously is
subjective which is sentience the
ability to experience reality and to
experience suffering and pain and
well-being okay so like if there were
plants that had some degree of sentience
or animals that didn't you'd be okay
killing them yeah I would I be okay with
killing plants that they had sentience
yeah um great question so it depends
like obviously this is more it it
depends how practical it is now well I
guess that would then be win against me
so I'm glad you mentioned that
that then sort of gets back to the
original thing because first you made a
very sort of black and white statement
like for example sentience would be the
trade but now you're saying that
practicality does actually play a role
so maybe it's not so black and white to
begin with right well you don't need to
kill animals to get nutrition or
anything like that you need to eat
plants and you obviously will kill
animals in the process of cropping
plants well but hold on a second let's
explore the hold on a second you're
saying you don't need to eat animals but
you need to eat plants there are tribes
that basically subsist on animal meat
animal blood and animal milk that they
don't need to do that any more than
anyone needs to or doesn't need to eat
plants but they seem to be getting by
without eating plants right okay so now
if they if they need to if they don't
have a way of growing crops or a hunter
or like gathering plants and berries and
that sort of thing and they need to kill
animals I would say they would be
justified in that okay so then sentience
is not really the black-and-white trait
that you're saying is the most important
consideration there's other traits that
are more important
like need exact exactly it's it's based
on necessity exactly oh so then what a
sentience have to do with it well that's
kind of the baseline that that's the
baseline and I just think since we live
in a in a society to where that it's not
needed for a nutrition or health or
anything like that I see it as
completely unnecessary to kill a
sentient being for basically no reason
other than a pleasure
so like scallops don't appear to be
sentient are you ok with scallops sea
scallop eating I'm not sure I'm pretty
sure they do have some sort of nervous
system that they you know I'm not sure
with the scallops I don't need them just
because it's I I'm not a scallop beer I
don't find it to be tasty but I mean if
so taste matters actually it sounds like
you're saying in this case you care more
about the taste of scallops than their
sentience no no if they are stinky and I
wouldn't eat them but if you're not
you're saying you don't like the taste
exactly I wouldn't see them though
they're not exactly alright I appreciate
it I don't know that we're getting too
much further but it's a very very
interesting conversation I'm glad you
called in and I'm gonna let you go I
think most of the the audience just gets
so mad when vegan stuff comes up and I
think I might have indulged that longer
than I should have we're gonna take a
quick break don't hang up if you're
holding because we are taking more calls
after the break stay on the phone line
six one seven eight three zero 4750
we'll be back to the phones right after
this